so let's talk about the last stance
okay the first time you and i sat down i
brought up lebron james and you had at
one point said lebron james was a closer
but you said that like 12 years ago or
10 i don't know the exact timeline
you said that even maybe when the book
came out you considered him a closer not
necessarily cleaner and you have the
whole cooler
right closer cleaner and the cleaner
guys like michael
and all these guys that are cleaners
okay great
he's a cleaner now he's a okay so here's
my question for you here's my
question for you um he's got four now
he's a laker now he's one with miami
he's one with cleveland he's one with so
he won for the city he won for two miami
he's over here now okay
do you think the last dance is the worst
thing that ever
happened to the argument of him being
the greatest and passing of michael
i don't even think so before the last
listen i'm going to be subjective on
this obviously because of my
relationship
we're not running for officers don't be
right with michael no no i'm not
but i'm just i i'm just saying all right
i think even before the last stance it
just wasn't
the only reason i say this is because
here's here's why i say this
so i'm 42 i think if you're above 35
there is no argument correct okay
there's no argument right
but do you think the 22 year old guy the
28 year old the 26 or maybe they didn't
get a chance to watch
saturday morning michael's coming up
against chicago he scored 52 points 55
points all this other stuff you would
see the guy's killer instinct
do you think the 22 year old like a
generation that missed watching this guy
play said
that guy's a scary guy to face up
against do you think
last dance hurt those guys's argument
oh yes it just it's just
there's so many the younger i i've had
so many people that come up to me
and say the footage of mj on youtube
is enhanced there's no way there's no
way anybody can do it
they're like they're just photoshopping
yeah they're just like jumping there's
just like there's no way he there's no
way
there's no way he can do that all right
and i've had so many individuals now
they're just like
it's just like because they didn't get a
sin they're just like mj's just a myth
and ghost to us
we hear all these we hear all these
stories and we
you know we've heard all these things
and it's just
they just can't they just can't comfort
they just can't comprehend it
they just they just can't comprehend so
the debate for you
it wasn't even a debate before but the
debate for you even afterwards nothing
changed for you but for somebody else
maybe they said
this wasn't my lebron's probably
watching that thing saying
oh they're going to say this they're
going to say that they're going to say
this that's not good
because you know lebron's a legacy guy
he said i'm chasing the ghost so it's
not like he hasn't put it out there
right when he came out and said he's
chasing one guy when he dunked the ball
and he's looking at
yeah so he's sending a message he is
sending him i wasn't looking at him i
was just dunking the ball
you know what he's doing okay so
who's on your top five all time do you
have a top five all time where you go
you know
let's say michael's the greatest and the
second do you have that
i don't have a top five of
be michael's going to be on there all
right
um i'd have to put i'd have to put
well you know what here's the thing if
you look at depending on the error of
the game if you're just
it could it could be it's so different i
mean if you're looking at the older game
you watch
you definitely want shaq in there all
right you're just the way he was
probably
the most the most dominant player that
he just gave him the ball and he just he
just literally ran through everybody
it i would probably i would want uh
i would take mj i would take kobe
i'd put lebron
larry bird
and who would my big be
yeah shag kareem wilt
maybe akeem but he would probably yeah
you know i work with akeem so it's kind
of difficult for me to keep him all keep
him off that list but the way the game
is played now is just like
i'd say shaq shaq yeah
that's a great list right there that's
you know you got
it's hard to leave with burden top five
yeah you know why in this game here
people forget he's another one you go
watch this he could do
every larry bird on a game decided
i'm just going to go shoot with the left
hand today
who does that he's like you're so bored
with the competition
that you come out and says
i'm going to beat these guys with the
left i'm going to go on
i don't know if it was the first half or
ever he says i'm just going to shoot the
ball with the left hand
who does that who
who who does that he wasn't afraid of
anybody
nobody and could do it all yeah could do
it could do it all
you know one of the reasons i put
obviously defense isn't a isn't a
primary thing
in this sport anymore but you know
obviously we know michael could play
unbelievable defense we know kobe could
play under
unbelievable defense uh lebron when he
chooses
he can play he he can he can lock them
down
if they do get around anybody you got
this big mon you got this big monster in
the
middle destroy you scared the hell out
of you and hit
all those individuals the one thing they
have is the ability to make everybody
else around them better
that's the thing they all have the
ability to make everybody
else dr jay comes out
and he talks about i'm sure you saw when
he comes down he says hey you know what
do you think about your top five and he
puts his top five it says first team
second team first team oscar robertson
jerry west elgin baylor bill russell
will chamberlain which obviously that's
his error
get it and then he says second team he
would put magic
michael larry malone kareem the second
team so obviously kobe is not on the
list if you had to choose between i
think the way he did it is positions one
two three four five is the way he did it
so he chose kobe over uh he chose
michael over kobe he chose magic over
steph curry he chose bird over say
lebron james he chose
malone over duncan and he chose kareem
over shaq
right and then they asked him they said
wait a minute where's lebron on this
list
and uh he said what were his words he
says he is the guy who has led the
change
in terms of super teams when he put
together a team in miami he put together
a team in cleveland as well and he put
together a team in la
so he can pick his own team i ain't
going to pick my own team the guy turns
around and says
i'm sure he said he says well lebron's
verdict would be
there's been super teams for a long time
everybody's had super teams you guys had
super teams there was typically three or
four all-stars on the same team he says
yes
last words yes but we didn't go
recruiting
players he did so one thoughts on what
he says
two what do you think about lebron not
being on his top five
well i mean obviously the top five is
what you said that that's his heir these
are the people that he knows with listen
when you go to war you're gonna go with
what
you you you need to go to war with the
makeup
of the people that you know that you can
trust you know your allies
these are his allies make sense these
are his out
by the way it's a great list it's a
great list
you literally got the records wilt has
is unbelievable
you talk about championships you know
everyone that that that's
that's the guy elgin baylor was that the
first
person to do all this stuff the triple
double here jerry west
logo the local yeah does anything
anything else needs to be
anything else needs to be said so that
says it this was an era
these are a lot of these individuals he
competed you know he competed he had
he competed against uh dr j competed
again
you know a famous fight with him and uh
when
he was holding that was moses malone
holding him somebody was holding a
bird by the neck and julius punch him
three times
away so you know what whatever it is and
you know michael is obviously everybody
said you know he's the
he's a heir apparent to to die to dr j
so he's had he's had all the respect
here you know obviously i'm not
he did it he did it by he did it by
position
all right what if i'm putting this
if i'm putting this team together i
would um
if i had to take one person out out of
here
what depends on if i had to take one
person out of my
i second a feeling i know who you're
gonna take out karl malone who'd you put
him
instead of him duncan
i would put yeah i mean out of this team
keeping lebron out of here if we're
gonna keep lebron out of here
all right i would put down i would put
dumb even if you think about this i
don't know if
i would put charles before a call i
almost
i'll put charles before carl really yeah
i almost think he went 60s 70s 80s 90s
because i don't think he went
2000 2010 and today because maybe he's
going through era
then he's going through the greatest i
don't know if that's going to be his top
five list
himself but uh you know again the last
dance when i watched i was sending you a
text i'm like
tim this is insane with the stories that
you're hearing about the sky left and
right everything that you're hearing
it's true that's what makes it when they
recorded it did they
know when they recorded that season did
they know eventually they're gonna do a
last dance
so that that was the plan so that was
always the plan
but the only person that didn't sign off
phil or michael was michael everybody
else signed off
what years ago like i'm not signing off
he goes
when it's time or when i decide to do
this i will sign off
and originally it wasn't even supposed
to come it was supposed to come out in
the fall
by the way i mean timing-wise you have
the timing kind of worked in their favor
yeah so they were just like the last two
episodes weren't even done when it when
it started
the last two episodes were not done
they were wait so so when we sat down
and we watched the first week on sunday
night
they had still not finished the last two
episodes the last two episodes were
still
not done because they hadn't planned on
showing it until but then because
of the pandemic and everything had and
you know everybody was like everybody
so they they literally went in and asked
hey
we need we want to move the production
up so they got in to
move the production up and it was you
know that's every everybody
the one thing i i have to say about
michael and this is why i put him above
everybody
whether it is kind of like tiger also
whether you were a basketball fan or a
golf fan
you were a fan of that you watch if you
didn't enjoy golf
you would literally you'd look up the
paper to see what tiger did or where he
was playing what was going on
yep i had so many people that's i'm not
a basketball fan but i'm a michael
jordan fan
so you had those those individuals
transcended individuals that
had no interest in that so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]